en los últimos vídeos hemos aprendido
que las configuraciones de los
electrones en los átomos no son tan
sencillas como en la configuración
clásica de órbitas neutrón yañez que es
el modelo del electrón devore seguiría
revisando este modelo porque me parece
que es un punto importante si este es el
núcleo que recordemos es un puntito
chiquitito en comparación de todo el
volumen del átomo y en lugar de que el
electrón gire en órbita alrededor del
núcleo que sería como los planetas
orbitan alrededor del sol en lugar de
tener órbitas tenemos orbitales los
cuales son funciones de densidad de
probabilidad así que un orbital digamos
que este es el núcleo se describiría si
tomamos cualquier punto en el espacio
alrededor del núcleo la probabilidad de
encontrar un electrón ahí así que de
hecho en cualquier volumen de espacio
alrededor del núcleo el orbital no será
la probabilidad de encontrar al electrón
dentro de dicho volumen
y si fuéramos a tomar muchas imágenes de
los electrones digamos que en el primer
orbital y es así como no sea el primer
orbital apenas podemos verlo pero es una
esfera alrededor del núcleo y es el
estado de energía más bajo en el que
puedes estar un electrón así que si
tomamos muchas imágenes de los
electrones digamos que son imágenes del
helio el cual tiene dos electrones ambos
electrones estarán en el orbital 1 ese
que luce así si tomáramos una imagen que
quizá estaría ahí y en la siguiente
imagen quizá el electrón se encuentre
por allá y después el electrón esté acá
y después por allá si seguimos tomando
estas imágenes tendremos muchas de ellas
en las que los electrones están muy
cercanos y después se van haciendo un
poco más escasas mientras nos alejamos
más y más del núcleo como ven es mucho
más probable encontrar al electrón cerca
del centro del átomo que encontrarlo
alejado de éste aunque pueden tener
alguna imagen en donde el electrón está
hasta por aquí
por lo que el electrón podría
encontrarse en cualquier parte pero si
viéramos múltiples observaciones verán
cuál es la función de probabilidad que
está describiendo es decir hay una menor
probabilidad de encontrar al electrón en
este pequeño cubo de volumen del espacio
de lo que hay para encontrarlo en este
otro pequeño cubo de volumen del espacio
y cuando ven estos diagramas que dibujan
este orbital así digamos que lo dibujan
como una capa como una esfera y tratan
de hacer que se vea tridimensional
digamos que esta es la parte de afuera
de esta y el núcleo se encuentra en
algún lugar adentro nos dicen que si
dibujamos un corte transversal donde
podríamos encontrar al electrón el 90%
del tiempo nos dicen bueno podemos
encontrar al electrón el 90% del tiempo
en este círculo y si yo fuera a hacer
este corte transversal pero de vez en
cuando el electrón no puede aparecer
fuera de esta parte después todo es
probabilístico así que esto aún puede
suceder cierto en el vídeo anterior
dijimos ok los electrones general en los
orbitales desde el estado más bajo de
energía hasta el estado más alto de
energía lo pueden imaginar pero digamos
que estoy apilando cubos yo pondría los
cubos desde el estado más bajo de
energía si éste fuera el suelo pondría
el primer cubo en el estado más bajo de
energía digamos que puedo poner el
segundo cubo también en el estado más
bajo de energía aquí
pero yo solo tengo este espacio para
trabajar así que pondré el siguiente
cubo en el siguiente estado de energía
en este caso no esta energía se
describiría como energía potencial
cierto este es sólo un ejemplo clásico
de física newtoniana pero es la misma
idea con los electrones una vez que
tengo dos electrones en el orbital 1s
digamos que la configuración electrónica
del helio es 1 s 2 el tercer electrón no
puede ir a este mismo orbital pues solo
acaben los electrones la forma en la que
lo imagino es que estos dos electrones
que ya están van a repeler al tercero
que quiero agregar así que este tiene
que ir al orbital 2s si ahora vamos a
dibujar al orbital 2s encima de este
otro se vería algo así donde yo tengo
una alta probabilidad de encontrar
electrones en esta capa que está
esencialmente alrededor del orbital 1s
así que ahora sí quizás estuviera
trabajando con litio solo tendría un
electrón extra este electrón extra
podría estar aquí en donde observé ese
electrón extra pero
vez en cuando podría aparecer allá
podría aparecer por aquí o por allá pero
la mayor probabilidad está por aquí así
que dónde va a aparecer el 90% del
tiempo será como en esta capa que está
alrededor del centro recuerden cuando lo
visualizan en tres dimensiones esto lo
cubriría así que sería esta capa
es por eso que la dibujaron aquí esta es
la 1s que es la capa roja y después está
12 la segunda capa de energía que es
esta capa azul da acá podrán observar la
mejora en estas capas de energía más
altas donde la séptima capa s de energía
es esta área roja después tenemos el
área azul luego la roja y después la
azul así que creo que ya se dieron una
idea de que cada uno de ellos es una
capa de energía como ven se van sobre
poniendo los orbitales de energía uno
encima del otro pero probablemente vean
esta otra cosa de aquí el principio
general recuerden es que los electrones
llenan los orbitales desde el orbital de
más baja energía hasta el orbital de
mayor energía por lo que el primero
avital que se llena es 1s
este es el 1 esta es la s este es uno
ese en el cual caben dos electrones el
siguiente que se llena es 2 es que
también puede albergar otros 2
electrones el siguiente
y aquí comienza a ponerse interesante
sella en el orbital 2 p que está justo
aquí aquí noten que los orbitales p
tienen algo p subíndice z p subíndice x
de subíndice y qué significa esto si
observan estos orbitales p verán que
tienen forma como de mancuerna lucen
poco naturales pero en los futuros
vídeos veremos que son análogos a las
ondas estacionarias si observan hay tres
maneras de configurar estas formas de
mancuernas una es en la dirección zeta
arriba y abajo otras en la dirección x
izquierda derecha y la otra escena
dirección lleva adelante y atrás si
quisiéramos dibujar digamos que los
orbitales p esto es lo que llegaríamos a
continuación de hecho se llenará un
electrón aquí otro electrón acá y
después otro electrón allá y después
llenaremos otro electrón y hablaremos
sobre los espines y cosas parecidas más
adelante les puedo adelantar que el
espín se puede decir que es el giro del
electrón o el momento angular intrínseco
del electrón y luego lo llenamos aquí
acá
y esto se llama la regla de holmes y
quizá haga un vídeo dedicado a la regla
de home pero eso no es relevante en las
clases de química de primer año pero se
llene en ese orden y de nuevo quiero que
tengan la idea intuitiva de cómo se
vería esto y debo poner ver entre
comillas ya que es algo muy abstracto
pero si queremos visualizar los
orbitales pero digamos que estamos
viendo la configuración de electrones
del carbono en la configuración de
electrones del carbono los primeros dos
electrones van en 1 s 1 y 1 s 2 así que
se llena 1s 1 y 1 s 2
esa es la configuración para el ello
después pasa a la segunda capa la cual
es el segundo periodo cierto es por eso
que la llamamos tabla periódica
hablaremos sobre periodos y grupos en el
futuro
ahora vamos acá estamos llenando a 2s
estamos en el segundo periodo acá 12 se
llenan a estos 22 s 2 y ahora comienza a
llenar los hospitales pero comienza
llenando 1p y después los p seguimos en
la segunda capa así que es 2 s 2 2
p 2 la pregunta es cómo luciría esto si
quisiéramos visualizar este orbital
justo aquí los orbitales p bueno tenemos
2 electrones un electrón para ir
digamos que si esto es bueno voy a
tratar de dibujar unos ejes y dibujo
estos ejes de forma tridimensional y si
yo realizara muchas observaciones de
digamos que uno de los electrones en los
orbitales p como por ejemplo la
dimensión pz
algunas veces podría estar aquí otras
veces podría estar acá y después de
muchas observaciones tendrá él algo que
tiene más o menos esta forma de
mancuerna
después para el otro electrón que quizás
esté en la dirección x se hacen muchas
observaciones permítanme ponerlo en otro
color se verá así hacen muchas
observaciones y dicen caray es más
probable encontrar al electrón dentro de
esta forma de mancuerna pero también lo
podemos encontrar aquí o acá o allá esto
indica que hay una mayor probabilidad de
encontrarlo aquí que encontrarlo allá y
esta es creo yo la mejor manera de
visualizarlo lo que hemos hecho aquí se
llama configuración electrónica hay
varias maneras de hacer esto que se
enseñan en la clase de química pero la
manera en que a mí me gusta hacerlo es
tomando la tabla periódica y decir estos
grupos y cuando digo grupos me refiero a
las columnas estas van a llenarlas sus
capas s de estos orbitales se pueden
escribir la s aquí justo aquí estos de
aquí van a llenar los orbitales p de
hecho déjenme quitar el helio de la
imagen
estos toman los orbitales p
de hecho para poder entender esto
deberíamos tomar el helio y ponerlo acá
la tabla periódica es una manera de
organizar las cosas para que tengan
sentido pero en términos de tratar de
comprender los orbitales podríamos tomar
el helio y permítanme hacerlo usando la
magia de las computadoras lo cortamos y
lo ponemos por acá estamos en la primera
capa de energía la configuración del
hidrógeno es 1s uno sólo tenemos un
electrón en la sub que aparece de la
primera capa de energía la configuración
del helio es 1 s 2 y después
comenzaremos a llenar la segunda capa de
energía la configuración de litio es 1 s
ahí es donde van los primeros 2
electrones y después el tercer electrón
irá a 2s 1 y yo creo que ustedes están
comenzando a notar el patrón después van
al nitrógeno y dicen ok tiene 3 en el
psuv orbital p así que también podrían
comenzar al revés cierto estamos en el
periodo 2 así que esto es 2 p 3
y es ahí en donde irán en los últimos 3
electrones al orbital p después
tendremos a estos dos que van al orbital
12 s 2 y después los primeros dos o los
electrones que están en el estado de
menor energía que estarán en 1s 2 y así
que esta es la configuración de
electrones de el nitrógeno para
asegurarse de que hicieron bien la
configuración lo que deben hacer es
contar el número de electrones así que
dos más dos es 4 + 13 7 y como estamos
hablando de átomos neutros los
electrones deben ser iguales al número
de protones el número atómico es el
número de protones así que somos buenos
tenemos 7 protones cuando trabajamos con
los eses y los peces esto es algo
bastante directo si quisiéramos
encontrar la configuración del silicio
cuál sería estamos en el tercer periodo
1 2 3 y este es el bloque p aquí es la
segunda columna del bloque p es cierto 1
2 3 4 5 6 estamos en la segunda columna
del bloque p así que comenzaremos con 3
p 2
y después se llena hasta el bloque pe de
aquí que es dos peces y aquí está dos s
dos y después por supuesto se llega
hasta la primera capa antes de que pueda
llenar estas otras capas así que es 1 s
2 configuración electrónica del silicio
y podemos confirmar que debemos tener 14
electrones 2 2 3 4 6 10 10 + 2 es 12 + 2
es 14 estamos bien con el silicio creo
que me estoy quedando sin tiempo en el
siguiente vídeo comenzaremos a ver qué
pasa cuando llegamos a esos elementos o
el bloque de y yo creo que ustedes ya se
imaginarán que sucede comenzaremos a
llenar estos orbitales de que tendrán
formas aún más extrañas y la forma en la
que yo lo imagino para no perder mucho
tiempo es que mientras más nos alejamos
del núcleo habrá más espacio entre los
orbitales de baja energía para llenar
estos orbitales de formas extrañas pero
estando en un equilibrio y hablaremos
sobre las ondas estacionarias en un
futuro me refiero a que están en un
equilibrio porque están tratando de
acercarse al núcleo y a los protones
estas cargas positivas que le son tan
atractivas a los electrones pero al
mismo tiempo tratan de evitar las otras
cargas negativas de los electrones que
están en las capas inferiores o al menos
tratan de evitar sus funciones de
distribución nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo